Mash and his friends have overcome various hardships, but even
more severe trials
await them.The new people they meet are the
ones who control this magic society.They are the magicians who have been given the title of the staff of God.
They
make a fuss in order to protect their handsomeness and niceness. [Music] What will happen to these people who are so
good and so good? What will happen to the Candidate Selection Examination? It's the people who are
showing off their abilities, and such
childlike things are allowed to happen in this world.  Is that what you think?
That's what you think. I'm just going to watch over your junior's recklessness. From now
on, you'll have to create a miracle greater than the devil. I understand. I
've destroyed the perception of this world.
Kagami
Mac New Candidate Selection Examination  Broadcast starts from January 2024